[Musik]
heute in deutschland herzlich willkommen
russland schafft fakten in der ukraine
die welt in sorge vor einer eskalation
und berlin entscheidet sich für
sanktionen unsere themen
scholz stoppt nord stream zwei der
bundeskanzler legt das
genehmigungsverfahren für die
gaspipeline auf eis und russen und
ukrainer in deutschland was sie zu
putins vorgehen sagen
die börsen auf talfahrt der ölpreis
steigt das sind sichere indizien wie
groß die sorge vor dem ist was da jetzt
kommt trotz aller diplomatischer
bemühungen und völlig unbeeindruckt von
möglichen sanktionen hat russlands
präsident putin die hand ausgestreckt um
sich in der ukraine zu nehmen was er für
richtig hält zwei rebellengebiete im
osten vielleicht mehr denn wie er sagt
habe die ukraine gar kein existenzrecht
als staat nicht nur die nato sieht das
ganz anders und bundeskanzler scholz
sprach am mittag aus was er bisher stets
vermied die genehmigung für nord stream
2 wird gestoppt
es war diese unterschrift gestern mit
der der russische präsident putin die
unabhängigkeit der beiden
selbsternannten volksrepublik 'nen
erklärte eine unterschrift mit
weitreichenden folgen heute vormittag im
kanzleramt besuch des irischen
regierungschefs doch das deutsch-
irische verhältnis interessierte
angesichts der dramatischen entwicklung
in der ukraine niemanden mehr
stattdessen verkündete stolz das
vorläufige aus für die umstrittene
pipeline north stream 2
ich habe das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium heute
gebeten den bestehenden bericht zur
analyse der versorgungssicherheit bei
der bundesnetzagentur zurückzuziehen das
klingt zwar technisch ist aber der
nötige verwaltungsrechtliche shit damit
jetzt keine zertifizierung der pipeline
erfolgen kann und ohne diese
zertifizierung kann die pipeline nicht
in betrieb gehen eine schwere
entscheidung für die spd die bisher
immer an dem projekt festgehalten hatte
anders der grüne koalitionspartner der
schon früher das aus gefordert hatte
deutschland müsse in energiefragen nun
unabhängiger werden wenn sich die
realität ändert wo sich auch die
beurteilung der realität ändern und wir
werden diesen winter so schnell nicht
vergessen der wirt energiepolitische
politisch und strategisch konsequenzen
haben unterstützung von der union die
schon länger das aus für nord stream 2
gefordert hatte nord stream 2 kann nach
dieser eskalation nicht ans netz gehen
und das muss man auch ganz klar sagen
auch weitere sanktionen werden notwendig
sein die linke dagegen setzt auf
deeskalation auf diplomatie das
vorläufige aus für nord stream 2 für
dietmar bartsch nicht wirklich
konsequent es fließt kein gas durch nord
sind zwei wenn man hier wirklich ein maß
großer konsequenz an den tag legen würde
dann müsste man über nord stream 1 dann
müsste man über die leitung durch die
ukraine reden das tut europa aus gutem
grund nicht
sollte die lage weiter eskalieren
sollten weiter russische panzer in
richtung ukraine rollen dann werde es
neue sanktionen gegen russland geben
heißt es in berlin am nachmittag wollen
die eu-außenminister verkünden welche
weiteren schritte sie planen
thomas reichert in berlin bundeskanzler
olaf scholz hatte bisher und auch bei
seinem besuch in moskau vermieden von
nord stream zwei zu sprechen jetzt doch
der stopp kommt das zu spät
es kommt jedenfalls genau zu dem
zeitpunkt in die bundesregierung für
diesen verlängere angekündigt hat scholz
hat erklärt dass die anerkennung der
separatisten republiken und der
einmarsch dort eine grundlegend neue
situation geschaffen hätten und dass
diese situation auch eine klare
konsequenz für moskau haben müsse
deswegen also jetzt das aus für nord
stream 2 klar die ukraine und auch
baltische staaten hätten gerne vorab
sanktionen gehabt quasi als abschreckung
für russland dabei deutschland und war
noch andere eu staaten immer dagegen
jetzt wird deutlich dass es trotzdem
vorbereitungen für das aus vor 22 gab
wirtschaftsminister habeck hat einen
neuen versorgungs sicherheitsbericht
angekündigt der geprüft wird er gesagt
neue realitäten bräuchten auch eine
neubewertung und wie die aussehen wird
das kann man sich mit dem heutigen tage
auch vorstellen das ist das aus für noch
zum 2 wir sprechen gleich weiter thomas
reichert und schauen an dieser stelle
wie die reaktionen auf den stopp von
nord stream 2 in mecklenburg vorpommern
ausfallen das bundesland das außer
tourismus nicht viel wirtschaftskraft
hat setzt eigentlich große erwartungen
in das milliardenprojekt und trat allen
gegnern und davon gibt's schon länger
einige stets energisch entgegen jetzt da
war es klar an beiden enden dieser
pipeline wird es verlierer geben die
leitung ist seit monaten fertig gefüllt
und einsatzbereit und auch die station
im vorpommerschen lubmin die das gas ins
deutsche netz einspeisen soll könnte
liefern nur die zertifizierung stand
noch aus doch die wird es erstmal nicht
geben manuela schwesig hatte sich immer
wieder für das projekt eingesetzt wie
hier beim demonstrativ gemeinsam besuch
mit dem russischen botschafter in
vorpommern wie sie wissen steht die
landesregierung hinter dem projekt nord
stream 2 nord stream zwei muss zu ende
gebaut werden in der endphase hatte die
landesregierung selbst mit einer eigenen
stiftung aktiv den pipelinebau
logistisch unterstützt um die us
sanktionen zu unterlaufen im auftrag der
stiftung wurde gar ein eigenes
versorgungsschiff gekauft und betrieben
gazprom soll sich mit 20 millionen euro
an der stiftung beteiligt haben das land
mit 200.000 in dieser woche ist die
ministerpräsidentin
krankheitsbedingt nicht an bord nach der
kabinettssitzung tritt am mittag die
stellvertretende ministerpräsidentin vor
die kameras selbstverständlich
unterstützen wir auch diese entscheidung
der bundesregierung und wir haben uns
als land dazu entschieden die klima und
umwelt stiftung zu bitten ihre arbeit
ruhen zu lassen
damit liegt seit heute nicht nur nord
trieben zwei auf eis sondern auch die
umstrittene landesstiftung am abend will
das kabinett zu einer sondersitzung
zusammentreten
und damit noch mal zurück zu thomas
reichert in berlin es geht ab heute um
mehr als 9 stream 2 was wird sich jetzt
ändern aus deutscher aus europäischer
sicht am umgang mit russland
also zunächst einmal wird es sehr
schnell sanktionen der eu gegen russland
geben die wurden an das er sonst seit
wochen vorbereitet im moment sitzen die
eu-botschafter in brüssel besser um sie
auf den weg zu bringen die
eu-außenminister könnten sie bei ihrem
treffen heute nachmittag oder abend in
paris schon beschließen es geht offenbar
jetzt erst mal um vier punkte in der
milch um sanktionen gegen abgeordnete
gegen unternehmen gegen den handel mit
dieser separatisten region und außerdem
um sanktionen gegen den finanzwert
mögliche einschränkung des handels mit
russischen staatsanleihen die eu die
sich ausdrücklich mit re sanktionen im
köcher behalten klar ist jetzt im moment
und dann merkt dass in berlin dass da
dass dies ein tiefer einschnitt mit den
beziehungen zu russland ist hier ist die
rede von dass moskau dass putin die
ausgestreckte hand zum dialog beck
geschlagen habe dass das ein kühler
berechnen der bruch des völkerrechts
gewesen sei da entsteht das bild eines
bedrohlichen russlands und es wird das
kann man glaube ich heute schon sagen
die politik gegenüber russland auf jahre
prägen
danke für diese einordnung live aus
berlin thomas reichert
in seiner fernsehansprache gestern abend
ließ präsident putin tief blicken die er
die geschichte der ukraine sieht ein
land von lenins gnaden russland geraubt
durch den zusammenbruch der sowjetunion
und er machte keinen hehl daraus dass er
die zeit zurückdrehen will mit der
gleichen begründung hat er sich schon
einmal von der ukraine genommen was er
für richtig und russisch hält die krim
matthias kubitz mit einem blick zurück
und den fakten von heute
die ukraine seit 1991 ein unabhängiger
staat bis dahin die zweitgrößte sowjet
republik heute drehscheibe zwischen ost
und west und in sich sehr verschieden
vom einst habsburgischen lemberg nahe
der polnischen grenze bis zur russisch
geprägten industrieregion im donetsk
becken
dazwischen die hauptstadt kiew hier
beginnt die krise vor acht jahren auf
dem majdan weil sich die ukrainische
führung klar russland zuwenden will
demonstrieren zigtausende für eine
größere nähe zum westen mehr als 100
menschen sterben durch schüsse der
präsident flieht
moskau nutzt die instabile lage truppen
ohne hoheitszeichen rücken auf der krim
1 erfolgs referendum wird die halbinsel
russisch für den westen eine
völkerrechtswidrige annexion nur wenig
später pro-russische separatisten
besetzen teile der ostukrainischen
industrie bezirke lohans grundton jetzt
rufen unabhängige volksrepublik 'nen aus
seitdem herrscht dort krieg
das minsker abkommen zur befriedung
unter deutscher und französischer
vermittlung scheitert
nun hat putin wieder fakten geschaffen
indem er die unabhängigkeit der
selbsternannten volksrepublik der
separatisten offiziell anerkennt unklar
zur stunde ob sich diese anerkennung
auch auf die von der ukraine gehaltenen
gebiete hier in gelb erstreckt
sollten russische truppen jetzt wie von
putin angekündigt in die ost ukraine
einrücken würden dort russische und
ukrainische soldaten direkt
aufeinandertreffen
jetzt bricht auf was schon lange schwelt
und wofür man in all den jahren keine
lösung gefunden hat das minsker abkommen
das sogenannte normandie format alles
bemühungen mit deutscher beteiligung und
allesamt wie es scheint vergebens wie
sehen die jenigen dass die diesen
konflikt aus nächster nähe kennen russen
und ukrainer stimmen dazu gesammelt am
vormittag in berlin
beim zentrum liberale moderne ukraine
verstehen machen sie sich große sorgen
um das land um ihre familien sie wollen
und müssen irgendetwas tun erst die idee
bilder malen für eine demonstration
heute abend gegen das russische vorgehen
die ukraine wird standhalten steht da
auf englisch
mir geht es schlecht weil ich habe die
nacht fast nicht geschlafen als ich das
gehört habe ich habe bis zum letzter
minute gedacht dass es nicht wahr ist
und mir geht es natürlich schlecht weil
meine familie wohnt nur vier stunden
entfernt von dem klick gebet wir kommen
aus libro also meine familie wohnt auch
da und wenn ich jetzt meine mama frage
wie es ihr geht und was sie mir erzählen
kann sie macht ich weiß es nicht berlin
hat sowohl eine große ukrainischer als
auch russische gemeinde laut zahlen des
amtes für statistik leben rund 24.000
menschen mit ukrainischen wurzeln in der
hauptstadt und 60.000 mit russischen sie
haben eigene lokale vereine supermärkte
wie hier ein russischer in
berlin-lichtenberg was halten die
menschen von der aktuellen entwicklung
[Musik]
demokratie und auch an die anordnung der
ganzen welt niemand will das gut also
niemand aus meinen freunden aus meiner
generation befindet sich das
absolut schrecklich und
menschenunwürdigen und ich bin ich fühle
mit ukrainischen menschen also ich bin
total dagegen um 17 uhr ist eine
demonstration vor der russischen
botschaft in berlin geplant gegen putin
gegen krieg in der ukraine
zudem entwicklungen dieser krise sendet
das zdf heute abend ein spezial putin
auf kriegskurs wie reagiert der westen
gleich im anschluss an die 19 uhr
nachrichten und auch in der zdf- heute
bleiben sie stets auf dem laufenden
es ist das thema des tages aber passiert
es noch mehr schauen wir also auf
weitere nachrichten und beginne mit
corona das robert koch institut meldet
1902 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind 33
1315 weniger als vor einer woche die
zahl geht also deutlich zurück aber es
gibt erneut 306 todesfälle das sind
viele die sieben tage incidents ist
hingegen ebenfalls gesunken auf 1300 6,8
diejenigen die während dieser pandemie
besonders viel geleistet haben sollen
dafür auch endlich etwas bekommen damit
beginnt unser nachrichtenüberblick
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach hat
einen vorschlag für den lange
diskutierten pflege bonus vorgelegt
demnach soll er zur hälfte zwischen
fliegenden in krankenhäusern und
beschäftigten in der langzeitpflege
aufgeteilt werden von 550 euro für
vollzeitkräfte in der altenpflege ist
die rede im krankenhausbereich sollen
träger und gewerkschaften über die
jeweilige prämienhöhe entscheiden
einen tag nach dem verheerenden
großbrand in der essener innenstadt mit
drei verletzten und 35 zerstörten
wohnungen wird noch immer nach der
ursache geforscht die ruine des
wohnkomplexes seien wahrscheinlich
einsturzgefährdet so die feuerwehr
in der vergangenen nacht tauchten immer
wieder glutnester auf die gelöscht
werden mussten jetzt soll ein polizei
roboter die ruine erkunden
der volkswagen konzern will seine
sportwagentochter porsche an die börse
bringen die gespräche hierzu seien
bereits fortgeschritten teilte das
unternehmen mit eine abschließende
entscheidung sei aber noch nicht
gefallen über den börsengang war schon
länger spekuliert worden experten gehen
davon aus dass vw das eingenommene geld
in e mobilität investieren will
bleibt zum schluss noch das wetter
morgen gibt es am alpenrand letzte
schauer sonst eine mischung aus sonne
und wolken am nachmittag verbreitet
sonnig höchstwerte 7 bis 14 grad wir
schauen beide auf das was in der welt
geschieht und melden uns morgen wieder
14 uhr zur heute in deutschland
[Musik]